Tech billionaires wear them,
babies wear them,
even the US vice president is a fan.
Sneakers. Trainers. The tennis shoe.
Whatever you want to call them,
they’re everywhere -
maybe even on your
own feet right now.
Tens of billions of pairs are
manufactured every year.
The biggest athletic shoe companies
make more in revenue
than the GDP of some countries.
So how did a piece of rubber,
leather and canvas
become such big business?
Let’s go back to the late
19th Century.
New sports like croquet and
tennis required new footwear
to protect the grass lawns
they were played on.
Not long after, sneaker
brands started to appear.
Converse’s most famous shoe, the
All-Star, made its debut in 1917.
Two of the biggest names in the
sneaker game, Adidas and Puma,
were each founded
by a German brother.
Adi and Rudolf Dassler
got together in the 1920s
to make athletic shoes.
The Dassler brothers capitalised on
something that’s common sense today.
If you want people to buy your shoes,
get someone famous to wear them.
That person was
US Olympian Jesse Owens.
But Owens, a black athlete,
was set to compete at the
1936 Olympics in Berlin
at a time when Adolf Hitler
and the Nazis
were firmly in control
of Germany.
The Dassler brothers who, along
with many German industrialists,
had joined the Nazi party, took
a risk in approaching Owens.
The risk paid off when Owens went on
to win four gold medals.
It was an incredible coup -
a black man upstaging Hitler’s racist
ideology on the world stage.
And he was wearing Dassler shoes.
After the war, the brothers split,
each to form their own company -
Adi set up Adidas and Rudi, Puma.
In fact,
Adidas is an amalgamation
of its founder’s first and second
names, Adi and Dassler.
His brother Rudi tried the same
trick, and called his brand 'Ruda'
before realising that
it didn’t roll off the tongue.
But the story of sneakers
is not just about
finding the right name
for your product.
It’s also about marketing.
Nike sold huge numbers of shoes
during the jogging boom of the 1970s.
But when they wanted
to move beyond running,
they needed something
extra special.
And they found it in
basketball legend Michael Jordan,
making him the biggest athletic
spokesperson of all time.
The Nike-Jordan partnership
was a huge success
generating more than $100 million
in sales in its first 12 months,
rising to an incredible $3.6 billion,
or around £2.6 billion,
in revenue in 2020.
Nike was also adept at spotting
other opportunities.
Did you know they paid just $35,
or roughly £284, in today's money
for their famous Swoosh logo?
And that the famous Nike slogan
“Just Do it”
was inspired by the
last words, “Let’s Do it”,
of murderer Gary Gilmore
prior to his 1977 execution?
It’s not just athletes -
and death row inmates -
who inspire us to wear sneakers.
In the mid-80s, hip-hop group Run-DMC
signed a landmark deal with Adidas
paving the way for many more
lucractive partnerships
between shoe makers and artists.
Today, Kanye West and Rihanna
each have their own line of sneakers.
And they’re worth big bucks.
West’s collaboration with Adidas,
the Yeezy sneaker line,
was valued at over
£1.2 billion in 2019 .
But what does our appetite for all
these shoes mean for the world?
Environmentally they are
something of a disaster.
A single shoe can contain
65 different parts,
and hundreds of different
processing steps.
As you can imagine,
our shoes stick around in landfills
long after we’ve thrown them away.
A rubber sole might take
80 years to biodegrade.
Plastics and synthetics
take hundreds more.
Several sneaker companies
are experimenting
with recycled materials and more
sustainable production methods.
But the legacy of our love
affair with sneakers
will be with us for many,
many years to come.